situé sur le plateau d'autres ans dans
le vercors
la vie est rude et les hivers très long
les produits laitiers et les pommes de
terre ont pendant longtemps été les
ressources essentielles des habitants du
dauphiné avec leurs crèmes et leurs
pommes de terre ils ont inventé un
plaqué devenu célèbre le gratin
dauphinois
[Musique]
nous avons demandé à madame bernard de
nous montrer tous les secrets de sa
confection
on peut faire des pauses d'épluchures un
prix parce qu'à des la période et là ils
sont bien contents vous mais c'est plus
facile
oui bonjour monsieur
quelles qualités ses pommes de terre
cette qualité c'est la belge lavage oui
et ça celles que j'ai moi c'est là qu'il
chante i'm urgente à argentat comment
les autres qualités se briser le vrai
gratin il faut pas trop qu'il se brise
l'hiver de combien de temps à peu près
et bien cette année il a commencé pour
leurs poussins et oui le père confie me
sens bien en place et oui alors c'est
charmant sa vie comme mollets des
estivants 10 où vous vous êtes que ruud
est un pays de l'est je leur dis bah non
je ne suis pas si saint maur vous diriez
pas comme ça un titre pareil non bon
alors je m'en vais prendre mon lait je
vais mettre un petit peu de la crème
c'est du lait entier déjà du lait à peu
près 8
je le mettrais surtout au dernier moment
voilà alors je vais le faire chauffer
sur mon malaise pardon je pousse ça va
ça va mais ça va tenir
il faut le faire bouillir leur bouillir
imams et les pommes de terre que quand
le liboux bien parce que non il faut pas
se prend moins bon goût si si on mettra
la vence et la crème va fondre dans
l'est howie ouvrier a pas de problème et
puis je m'en vais remplir
ouais ça c'est un four à bois
c'est un four à bois les mets sur le gaz
ça va plus vite pour faire la belle a
juste pour prendre le bougnat pas je
fais cuire alors moi je veux comme je
vais faire mon jeu me met du voile poil
masses arabes y voilà bon maintenant je
vais peut-être laver les pommes de pin
disque puis en ligue les bras
attaqué par le ter sont lavés on le dit
on va l'écouter mais avant je m'en vais
froid qu'elle peut mon plat avec une
petite bosse die il paraît que ça donne
le goût est trop atteint meilleur j'ai
commencé comme p mais il faut pour me
montrer y est parce que je sais pas à
quelle et bangalore est occupé à ben
aussi fric on peut évidemment aussi
plein conclure oui tu as même cadre et
sa fille leila b mais aussi en y
injectant au total air alors bon c'est
donc face à un tour celui ci pour mieux
former eux-mêmes des couteaux pour bien
alors qu'il vole un coup et bien sûr
alors où va te couper la wii tous les
deux à huit très très faim oui aussi
fait qu'on peut voyager dans des petits
morceaux et j'ai entendu dire comme plus
cet effet meyer cité mais des fois un
peu précis alors enfin peu plus haut et
c'est pas grave si on fait des morceaux
qui sont pas très grand non non non non
pas henri dubied ya une épave a aucune
qu'est ce que vous mettez comme quantité
à peu près au jeu ça me rend pas bien
compte fait soleil un peu à l'oeil
oui c'est à dire que voilà le ce plat il
fait bien pour le même six 6 personnes 6
aimer personne a réussi un petit peu
moins
il faut quand même la vitalité de port
de tel pour que le gratin sauvier vos
bombes j'ai fait bouillir mon lait
sûrement gaz et maintenant qu'ils
bougent lemay somme aux fourneaux le
fonds doit avoir le fourneau à bois
d'oeuvre et puis je vais mettre les
pommes de terre
alors ça c'est pour le gratin dauphinois
cesse pour le dauphinois oui
je vois pas quand même s'est produit
parce que comme on ajoute les dea la
faille pis si un port c'est le pépère
mais tu cherches un patron de nouvelles
contraintes 1 dans le gratin dauphinois
n'a fait que les pommes de terre à
môtiers et puis j'ajoute encore un petit
peu d'ail bien fait et la mise en ajoute
un tout petit peu parce qu'il faut il
vouloir épouser il vous revient sur
l'année merci beaucoup
il faut soit un petit peu relevée de
pêche
motus mes pommes de terre cuites à la
moitié je retire ma casseroles et je
vais avait ajouté lé nom que je vais le
saluer le point vaut un petit plus des
deux grosses de grosses passer de ses
déboires de foire puis une bonne chère
beaucoup d'eux seuls oui 2 euros
beaucoup beaucoup je savais même jamais
suffisamment fait il vaut mieux pas
assez en ajoutons enfin voilà alors je
vais casser mes yeux jamais deux portes
la cantrie c'est un grande plage envie
de croiser la rdc suffisent donc deux
pour super six à huit personnes
et c'est là que ça s'est fait à bord
vous d'avoir donné merci beaucoup
tous les bateaux en eaux mettrait 20 ans
on est plus jeune raymond courrière
couillard ap oui bétonnière a évolué et
j'aimerais ça c'est exact projet en est
encore une bonne note alors voulu facile
plein nous allons mettre le goût hier
les oeufs battus en omelette sur le
gratin sur le gratin alors après je
remue un peu en bourse à ceux ça se
mélange bien
en puisant voilà il ya plus qu'à mais
maintenant il n'y a plus qu'à mettre au
four ou l'impasse éleveurs je me mettais
les petites noisettes 10 parisienne et
un couteau encore oui voila merci vous
alors on n'a plus qu'à le mettre au fond
il est prêt et je crois que par là comme
les populations plus à m'occuper petit
bleu mieux ça doit être suffisant c'est
un four très chaud d'un show il bruine
son île chaud voilà on referme en attend
une demi-heure et oui elle donc le
gratin dauphinois c ou faire le gratin
la crème que vous faites ici c'est un
plat complètement locale parce que vous
nous faites vos pommes de terre vous
faites votre crème noyau de nouvelles
sur place puis vous comprenez autres
points n'ayant pas bletterie vous aviez
des personnes des militaires me faisais
le fromage il faisait le cers nage
sassenage oui et je vois mes parents
nous avions écrit mu alors nous avions
quand même toujours d'un crime mais le
gratia petit mangeait tout moment dans
toutes les maisons de du village quoi ça
ça continue oui oh oui pour ça continue
alors voilà le gratin dauphinois le vol
je pense qu'il est bien cuit et mais
elles ont sorti un superbe envie safer
et vendra des nombreuses familles des
travaux il est bancal et plus sûrement
plus relevé que l'autre alors ça
ensuite on va goûter gratin à la crème
il faut voir là où est mon mari lui
égaux merci à autrans on fait surtout le
gratin à la crème il se prépare un peu
différemment on fait cuire complètement
les pommes de terre dans le lait puis on
ajoute un grand bol de crème et on passe
le plat 20 minutes au four à vous de
prouver à tous que ça parce que non
[Musique]